I think initially one has to really
begin by beginning to think about the
nature of the self as it relates to the
whole concept of deep time generally
speaking when the postmodern self thinks
about his or her own identity we tend to
think of our own experience in in terms
that are incredibly personal incredibly
small we relate to the whole notion of
history usually in relationship to our
own personal life experience and we tend
to over-exaggerate the the significance
of of our own personality shines I don't
want that the sound the wrong way but
there there is a there is a at this
particular time it seems that most of
the luckiest people in the world are
suffering from a cultural epidemic which
is called extreme narcissism which is an
exaggerated self-importance which is
really a cultural problem more than it
is a personal problem and in the extreme
narcissism the exaggerated sense of self
concern makes it very difficult for us
to really begin to see and feel beyond
the boundaries or own personal sense of
self personal ideas of cell to being
able to see ourselves as as very much
related to the first cause or the
original energy and intention that
initiated the creative process because
when we get when we begin to relate our
own as I was saying earlier our own
capacity for consciousness and cognition
to the original that original leap from
nothing to something the the sense of
what it means to be ourselves in a sense
of nothing less than cosmic importance
begins to dawn on us and not not in a
way that is artificial or manufacturer
but we really begin to into it and feel
that we are really the the to the
leading edge of the interior of the Big
Bang and what that means is that you
know the universe has an exterior and
has an interior so the exterior of the
cosmos is matter and the interior of the
cosmos is interior already or our
capacity
for interior d or subjectivity so the
the human capacity for interior t and
subjectivity very specifically the new
uniquely human capacity for self
reflective awareness and self reflective
awareness means i have the that that
that as a human being i have the
capacity to be aware of awareness for
through self reflective awareness
consciousness can become aware of itself
so in a highly diwali evolved sentient
life form who has evolved to the degree
that he or she has the capacity for self
reflective awareness the universe can
begin to behold itself regard itself
realize itself and recognize itself and
ultimately begin to consciously take
responsibility for its own future and
and when we begin to see that how
marvelous how extraordinary how precious
is this very a very sophisticated
mechanism and capacity of self
reflective awareness we begin to see we
begin to appreciate that the reasons why
we are so important is not because of
our exaggerated sense of self-importance
or in narcissism but but because through
us through this through this capacity
for self reflective awareness the energy
and intelligence that initiated the
creative process can begin to behold
itself and begin to consciously take
responsibility for itself because as I
was saying before God fell out of the
sky what is 400 years ago and is now
beginning to reemerge in the within the
self reflective awareness of individuals
the leading edge who are beginning to
realize these things where's God is not
other ultimately God is not other than
self